hey everybody thanks for joining us I'm
Lauren Zima and I'm Kevin Frazier and
you know for the first time Lauren we
are hearing what really went on in that
hotel in Paris when Kim Kardashian was
robbed and it's very interesting because
we had a chance to sit down with the man
who was working the front desk that
night he he's not the concierge he's not
a security guard he was the guy who was
working the front desk and in an
exclusive interview we sat down with him
and talked about what really happened
because he was there while Kim was held
at gunpoint so was he and we learned a
few things that really I think surprised
a lot of people as he talked and told us
details because initially we thought Kim
was targeted because they wanted her
jewelry and then everybody and you know
that it was just a heist and Kim was the
person who they wanted but we've learned
so much more now we've learned so much
more Kevin that's what has blown my mind
about this interview I watched it live
yesterday as et zone Jennifer Perot sat
down with him in Paris and his name is
Abdul Rahman he's not revealing his last
name for security reasons but he's going
by that and we're gonna take you through
basically finding out that so many
things that you thought were what went
down you thought how Kim was targeted
turns out according to him to not be
true let's take a listen to how he says
Kim was reacting really quickly but also
guys we want we want you to know that we
are gonna be listening to your questions
in your comments on Facebook right now
so let us know whatever questions you
still have about the story that has
rocked the world but here's how he said
Kim reacted that night it also is
probably very firm I told her she
wouldn't speak French so she didn't
understand though she knows why she was
screaming like him so he's just saying
Kim was terrified the whole time talking
about the ages of her kids saying I'm a
mom a that stuff didn't surprise me as
much that's how you'd react
yes and I also think that Kim while
caught off while caught by surprise the
one thing we do learn is that she
offered up the ring and that is a
fascinating thing that I think before we
thought she was targeted because of that
ring
she's offered up her ring but they
wanted cash and that's what we have
learned also that they came in and they
kept asking for cash they didn't ask for
jewels they'd asked for anything
specific specific they just wanted money
and the one thing that Kim could provide
quickly that would save her life in this
case she felt was that big diamond ring
that's what's so crazy about it is
really the story has been so much
speculation that the thieves were after
Kim's ring specifically it it almost
made it seem like this Ocean's eleven
caper right like they are going in they
know the jewels that they want it's this
very heist scenario and that was a
pretty new ring that Kanye had given her
worth millions yes and so we're thinking
Kim is flaunting everything on social
media everybody knows she has this ring
and everybody in the world is thinking
they targeted that specifically and
according to Abdulrahman not the case at
all actually let's go ahead and and take
a listen to how actually unprepared he
said that the thieves were I mean he was
telling us telling Jen that they
seemingly had never been to the hotel
that they didn't seem to know how many
floors or how many rooms were there well
not only that but also when you know he
said they came to the door and they held
a gun to the door through the through
the gate and that's when he first
realized oh this could be a problem and
he let them in but they had no idea
where they were gonna go it was kind of
haphazard and what was going on exactly
so he actually used the word improvising
he felt that they were improvising and
let's take a listen to what he said
first happened how they made him wait
for several minutes when they first got
to the hotel no just a door and there at
the front desk just waiting for a client
yeah they waited like for ten minutes
and it's very long yeah that's a long
time yeah that's probably the longest
ten minutes of your life no very long
and you know in a stressful time like
this the the time change maternally you
know so he actually says that he was
standing there with them and they were
just waiting for people to come in so
that they could rob them and let's
remember that night at the hotel Robin
Thicke was there
there were other stars like Jennifer
Lawrence had been there two nights
before so it is very popular hotel with
very big name stars so that's why I'm
sure they were assuming at some point
someone big is going to walk through
this lobby we can rob them we can run
out or they were gonna make a tour
through the whole hotel and hit a lot of
rooms it just so happened that Kim's was
the first room yeah he said that they
asked him you know about safes what
safes are in the rooms they seemingly
this is the hotel you're seeing it right
now
and they seemingly hadn't like mapped it
all out you know when I first heard
about this I'm thinking they had to go
in there with such a specific I mean
let's be honest we all thought that it
was an inside job when this first
happened we all said it's an inside job
and maybe just maybe the Kardashians are
involved there was a lot of people who
speculated about their involvement in
this and that was one of the first
things that he says he says they were
not involved Kim was not involved she
was terrified and she thought she was
gonna lose her life so that's where you
you kind of understand for the first
time okay this wasn't a joke this wasn't
some kind of stunt this was a real
robbery in Kim's life was in the balance
along with this gentleman who was
working the front desk but Lauren then
you turn around and you say okay if
that's the case then why do they go to
Kim's room first why did they target now
we know it just haphazardly and it's so
funny you see that's actually that's
what so many of you are asking Gretchen
is saying how did they get in her room
Angela why did he let them in he put
guests at risk so a lot of why questions
and what he has told us is you know
again and we knew this but they were
dressed as police I mean at first he's
thinking this is a Fashion Week incident
it is Paris Fashion Week right and then
the guns were pulled on him and once the
guns were pulled on him he was gonna
take them wherever they wanted to go and
you have to understand what a gun is
being pointed at you remember this man
is being held at gunpoint you're going
to go wherever they ask you to go and
according to him they did threaten his
life they said we will kill you
and as for how they got into Kim's room
I mean he is telling us that at first he
was trying to distract them he was
trying to not name names of who was
there but eventually again when you're
handcuffed when your life's at stake I
mean he said he was he was gonna do
whatever he could to stay safe I also
thought one of the other fascinating
things was the fact that they were
trying to figure out where the security
cameras were and they didn't have them
there weren't any there weren't any
skill and I think they were shot
just like everybody else has been
shocked throughout this investigation
like where's the video from inside the
hotel but apparently there were no
security cameras or in the ones there
were turned off for privacy sake for the
stars that were staying there so it's an
interesting kind of twist because even
the robbers were confused at first
according to Abdul Rahman it's not even
just celebrities he says dignitaries
according to him presidents have stayed
there and that what he says is the
celebrity clientele wants a certain
amount of privacy but here's the thing
I understand they want privacy but they
also need to be safe and after this
after this you will want those cameras
listen if you're doing business and
you're coming and going as you should
there shouldn't be a problem but it's
just very interesting and there's lots
more questions Jessica says who done in
any suspects um no I mean no one has
been brought in as a suspect
not only are there heavens has no one
been arrested in this but they really
still don't have a clear picture of who
these men were and that's where it gets
really weird that they haven't even
formed a picture of who these guys it
was interesting to me too that
Abdulrahman told us it again they just
seemed like they've never been there
before according to him come raining
hungry I'm reading I'm reading it yeah
yeah Edward says I hope that the hotel
gets more security so scary yeah Edward
I believe that they will get more
security but also I think that they have
forever lost their celebrity clientele
you know I saw Robin Thicke just night
before last at a film premiere and you
know he doesn't even want to talk about
what went on that night because he just
like listen I don't even want to talk
about it because it could have been him
just as easy as it was Kim and I think
that for Kim an inch another interesting
note that we learned is that Kim was
bound and gagged but the her phone rang
and it was Pascal her bodyguard and when
the body when it rang and the the
gentleman from the front desk mr. um
Abdulrahman mr. Abdul Rahman's said hey
that's her security calling and they
could be coming any moment that's what
scared them off right it's almost this
both sort of blessing in a curse because
Kim is the one that's targeted first
they come after her she has this
terrible experience but because her
bodyguard who was with her all the time
he was just out with Kourtney that night
at an event with Kim's sister Courtney
but because he called to see if she was
okay that's what scared
the thieves off and that's what what
according to mr. bill ramen that's what
happened do you want to get into guys as
Kevin said it was just so crazy because
we're all thinking they're there for the
ring and according to this man who mans
the front desk that was not where they
were there at all listen to what he said
about how they asked for money first the
guy was asking for money or his money
money money you know we're not on
without all your friends you know and at
that moment I I think she believed that
he was there for her ring I mean they're
not there for the ring but is they see
money over and over and over money over
and over again and then Kim offers the
ring because she's like this is the one
thing I haven't look I get that she was
afraid for her life I think the real
concern becomes here with this situation
that now we understand how dangerous it
was that she was held at gunpoint that
it wasn't a stunt but people always get
skeptical when they turn on the TV and
they see it on Keeping Up with the
Kardashians you know I remember being in
Las Vegas when Lamar with the Lamar Odom
situation and you know the family being
so serious you won't see this on TV
we're not filming nothing will you know
this is life or death and then you turn
on the television and that's the main
theme of the season once again so you
say that is this going to be the theme
of the season will we see Kim right
after the robbery on cell phone video
because that's where people start to
begin start to begin to get skeptical
about the entire situation but what we
learned from this this man working the
front desk is that it was a real robbery
and these were kind of bumbling robbing
robbers that tried to find their way
through this this hotel and find as much
money as they could and they weren't
necessarily targeting Kim Kardashian
well in like you said she handed over
the ring herself which you know she's a
mother she keeps screaming about her
kids he told us that at one point she
was just saying the ages of her children
to try to get them to listen to her
because there's also that language
you know she doesn't really speak French
they didn't understand English and
Abdulrahman told us he was the
interpreter at some points but this is
what happens when Kim offered up the
ring you know they said just a ring she
gave the guy and doing when he took it
like they I don't know it took it like
this oh it's nice and he put it on his
pocket I mean because that's a it's a
huge ring that's 49 for him yeah for him
it was just a ring I think
so he says Kim offers the ring the guy
throws it in his pocket as if it's just
a ring oh it's it's it's nice he's
accustomed to costume jewelry but um I I
think at that point she believed she was
the target of this thing and and you
know they took some other jewels and
some of it they dropped in the street as
they were escaping and they are and
police are trying to get DNA off that
jury that was lost but at the end of the
day she's alive you can claim that ring
on insurance and get it back it's fine
Kim has returned um kind of her public
life she has spent the last two nights
going to see Kanye perform at the forum
here in Los Angeles um while he has had
his sold-out shows there and so she is
kind of slowly but surely returning to
regular life but in both instances she
has gone out now with armed security and
her life has changed forever that's her
new reality as the armed security
because she's shaken by this thing so it
will be interesting to see how it
affects the rest of the people um you
know Kendall was at the Lakers
basketball game last night you know and
you couldn't see security in in the
shots when they showed her courtside
they're watching her alleged boyfriend
I'm Jordan Clarkson play for the Lakers
but you know you look at that situation
you wonder how will life change for all
of them and will they have more security
and will there be more scrutiny Emily at
all times we watched well and we still
have not seen Kim make that major social
media return right I mean that's what
everybody's waiting for what is her
first post gonna be what's her first
statement gonna be because she has been
absent on Instagram on snapchat
platforms she used to be on all the time
what I think is so interesting is you
know that night say Pascal had been
there he did not have a gun multiple
people have said that and they do so
much traveling to all these different
countries where laws are different gun
carrying laws are different so that'll
be interesting to see so when you
mentioned Pascal that is her security
guard and he is guarded lots of stars
from Sierra to the black-eyed peas to
lots of balls down there yeah he is
excellent he is a very big man who can
hurt you very easily and I think that he
would have been there and it would have
been a different situation if they had
seen Pascal it might have been a
different phone call from him
according to the front desk I scared
them off I mean so I don't yeah it is
interesting to to hear him tell this
story in here yes and I also think it's
interesting that people were blaming
Pascal if he had been there what you
know you wonder would it have been
different but he was dispatched to go
with you know Courtney and make sure she
was okay and so that's what he did he
did his job and I think there was an
expectation that Kim was relatively safe
in that hotel that has so many stars and
dignitaries and so I do like the
sentiment that where folks are saying
that hey you know what Kim a whether you
like him or not you do have to feel for
her being put in this life-or-death
situation because you well you don't
wish that on any of your well and I mean
you know another thing they're asking
for money money money Kim didn't have
very much money on her that and the
front desk man is telling us that it was
agitating him that she didn't have very
much cash so she's handing over the
rings she's screaming about her children
she's terrified according to him you
guys we are gonna wrap things up here
but again this is this guy's first time
on camera you have to watch this
interview it's gonna be tonight on et
you'll find out what Kim's final gesture
was to him that night it's gonna be
really compelling and I also hope you
guys watch and look at his demeanor look
at his demeanor throughout this
interview and I'm very curious if you
guys will send us messages back on
Facebook and tell us what you think
after watching him throughout this
interview when he's asked some very hard
questions the way he reacts it's
interesting it is so interesting to see
how people do react in these extreme
situations both when they're scared for
their lives and when they're having to
tell this traumatic story I was
surprised I was a little surprised it
was a little surprised all right guys
watch it tonight on you T thank you so
much for joining us and please like ET
on facebook because we're gonna continue
to bring you all the latest in breaking
news especially these exclusives that we
get like this thanks so much for
watching
you